in this video we're diving into the
origins of our favorite Marvels Captain
Marvel Miss Marvel and Monica Rambo or
Photon we'll focus on how they got their
powers in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
but we'll also touch on their comic book
Origins so let's get started Carol
Danvers also known as Captain Marvel is
one of the most powerful heroes in the
universe but how did she get her
incredible abilities well it all started
when she was a former United States Air
Force pilot who worked with Dr Wendy
Lawson a scientist who was secretly a
Cree named marll Lawson was working on a
project called the light speed engine
which used the energy of the Tesseract
and infinity stone that contained The
Power of space Carol was test piloting
the engine when they were attacked by a
group of cre led by Yan Rog who wanted
to steal the Tesseract for their war
against the Scrolls a shape-shifting
alien race Carol tried to destroy the
engine to prevent it from falling into
the wrong hands but the explosion
exposed her to the energy of the
Tesseract which infused her with Cosmic
Powers she was then captured by yon Rog
who gave her a blood transfusion that
made her into a cre human hybrid and
implanted false memories in her mind he
also put a device on her neck that
suppressed her full potential and
trained her as a member of an elite cre
military unit called Star Force Carol
eventually regained her true memories
and broke free from yon rog's control
with the help of Nick Fury a shield
agent who became her friend and Ally she
also learned that marll was actually
trying to help the Scrolls find a new
home and that the cre were the real
villains Carol then Unleashed her full
power and defeated yonr and his forces
as well as Ronin the accuser another cre
warlord who tried to destroy Earth with
his Fleet she then left Earth to help
the scrs find a new home and protect
other planets from the cre in the comics
Carol's origin story is somewhat
different she was exposed to a powerful
alien device called the psyche magnetron
which altered her DNA and gave her
superhuman abilities similar to Marvel's
who was also known as Captain Marvel at
the time she then took on the mantle of
Miz Marvel and later became Captain
Marvel after Marvel's death next up is
Kamala Khan our beloved Ms Marvel Cala
is a 16-year-old Pakistani American High
School student from Jersey City who
loves superheroes especially Carol
Danvers or Captain Marvel she also loves
writing fanfiction and playing video
games with their friends Nikia and Bruno
but Cala feels like she doesn't fit in
at school or at home because of her
strict parents and conservative culture
one day Cala discovered that she had
superpowers when she accidentally
activated a family heirloom bangle that
belonged to her grandmother the bangal
allowed her to manipulate no a
mysterious cosmic energy that flows
through all living things kamala's
powers include shooting out almost
crystal-like formations from her hands
and enlarging parts of her body when
necessary she can also create hard light
constructs such as Shields and weapons
Kamala decided to use her powers for
good and become a superhero like her
Idol Captain Marvel she made her own
costume and called herself Miz Marvel
inspired by Carol's name she then
embarked on various adventures in Jersey
City and Beyond eventually coming into
contact with Camron who was also a
mutant hybrid like her but used his
powers for evil in the comics kamala's
origin story is also different she was
exposed to teren mist a substance that
activates latent genes in certain humans
and gives them superpowers these humans
are known as Inhumans and have the their
own hidden Society ruled by blackbolt
and Medusa kamala's powers in the comics
include polymorphing all or parts of her
body into different shapes and sizes
last but not least we have Monica Rambo
also known as Photon Monica is a former
sword agent who has a close connection
to Carol daners her mother Maria Rambo
was Carol's best friend and fellow Air
Force pilot who helped her uncover her
past and fight the Creed Monica idolized
Carol and wanted to follow in her
footsteps but her mother died of cancer
while Carol was away in space Monica
then joined sword a division of Shield
that deals with extraterrestrial threats
she was also one of the victims of
thanos's snap which wiped out half of
all life in the universe she was brought
back 5 Years Later by The Avengers but
found out that her mother had passed
away during her absence Monica then got
involved in a strange phenomenon in
Westview New Jersey where Wanda maximoff
had created a reality altering hex
barrier that trapped the town's
residents and turned them into
characters of a sitcom Monica tried to
help Wanda and break the hex but
crossing the barrier multiple times
caused Monica's cells to be Rewritten
resulting in her developing superhuman
abilities these abilities allow her to
manipulate wavelengths of the
electromagnetic spectrum and see and
manipulate light energy she can also fly
and phase through solid objects Monica
then used her powers to stop Agatha
Hartness a powerful witch who wanted to
steal Wanda's magic and Hayward the
corrupt director of Sword who wanted to
weaponize vision's body she also
befriended Wanda and helped her cope
with her grief and Trauma in the comics
Monica's origin story is different from
the MCU she was a lieutenant in the New
Orleans Harbor Patrol who gained her
powers after being bombarded by extra
dimensional energy while trying to
prevent a weapon created by a criminal
scientist from exploding she then became
a superhero and took on the name Photon
and there you have it if you enjoyed
this video and want more content like
this don't forget to like And subscribe
and check out the video on your screen
too